تنفذوا النقابات العماليه فرنسيه اليوم
الثالث في اقل من شهر للمطالبه بتحسين
الشروط العمل وزياده الرواتب ومعاشات
التقاعد لمواجهه اعداء التضخم وارتفاع
الاسعار للمتابعه ينضم الينا من باريس
مراسلنا محمد البقالي محمد والاضراب
الثالث في اقل من شهر كيف تتعامل السلطات
مع هذه هذا النوع من الاضرابات التي تسبب
ادباء في النقل العام ومع المطالب بصفه
عامه
المستوى القانوني هناك تعامل كما يقترض ان
يكون في دوله
الدستور
تمكين المتظاهرين كما تشاهدون في هذه
المسيره في باريس من مواصلات او من القيام
بالتعبير عن احتجاجهم وعن غضبهم على
المستوى السياسي هناك مخاوف بطبيعه الحال
من شتاء سيكون اسيا لاننا نتحدث الان عن
ثلاث اضرابات في طرف ثلاث اقل من شهر
تقريبا وهذه التظاهره التي تشاهدون هي فقط
واحده من 150 وربما 2007 ستخرج في كل
انحاء فرنسا كل اسباب الغضب الاجتماعي
والسياسي تجمعت في فرنسا هناك موجه غلاء
غير مسبوقه قد التبخر ثم هناك نقابات قويه
في الشارع وغ من الرئيس ومن الحكومه
وتتهمما بانه تتهم الرئيس بان رئيس
الاغنياء وبان الحكومه انما تقوم
بتقديم المشاريع التي تخدم الفئات الاكثر
همم على المستوى الاجتماعي والاقتصادي
التي لديها وضع افضل الرئيس يوسف بانه
رئيس للابرياء اذن حاله الغضب الاجتماعي
حاله الاحتقان السياسي قوه النقابات في
فرنسا كما لا يوجد في اي بلد اوروبي اخر
رايينذر كل ذلك بان الشتاء لن يكون سهلا
على الاطلاق فالمطالم تتكرر هي ذاتها
لم تتغير الزياده الرواتب مساله التقاعد
معاشات التقاعد ثم هناك مشروع اخر
يوشك ان ربما سيكون له ما بعده مشروع
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون يريد ان يرفع سن التقاعد الى
الخامسه والستين او الرابعه والستين هذا
الامر يثيره غضبا شديدا لدى النقبات
التي كناها نسمع على امتداد هذه التظاهره
ان الحد الادنى للاجور يجب ان يرفع الى
الفيوم بينما الحد الاقصى للعمل يجب ان
يتوقف عند الستين بشكل عام هذا الذي
نشاهده وهي مجرد عينه ربما يمكن ان نصفه
هذه الحركات التسخينيه لما سياتي لك لان
همم اسباب الغضب والتوتر في فرنسا متوفره
ويمكن ان نقول اننا امام خلطه مشتعله
ونتذكره هنا همم
الصفراء وكيف انها بدات من حراك
ظهر في البدايه على انه حراك بسيط وعادي
لتتحول الى حركه احتجاجيه كان لها ما
بعدها شكرا جزيلا لك محمد البقالي مراسلنا
من باريس